this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's a new year's
resolution or a lifelong passion
start your journey to website glory with
squarespace check out their wonderful
all in one platform through the link in
the description below more on them in a
[Music]
bit
he's likely one of the five most
significant human beings to have ever
lived
gaius octavius commonly known as
octavian spent his entire life at the
beating heart
of roman politics the great nephew of
julius caesar he first supported his
famous relative
in his campaigns of conquest before
later becoming the avenging angel who
murdered caesar's assassins elevated
leadership position in the second
triumvirate
he then fought a war with mark antony in
cleopatra
a war that determined the very fate of
rome itself
yet while that epic tale alone would be
enough to fill any normal lengths video
it was only a preamble to the real
action
because it wouldn't be as octavian that
the boy's name
went down in history but as augustus
the first and greatest roman emperor
although he never used the term emperor
himself it was under augustus's watch
that everything we associate with the
roman empire came about
it was he who dismantled the republic
who transformed a sclerotic bureaucracy
into a long-lived superpower and who
became head of a family that would
produce
some of the most infamous rulers in all
of history in today's
very special double length episode
biographics is delving deep into the
life of octavian
the boy who birthed the roman empire
at the moment gaius octavius was born on
september 23rd 63 bc
it was into a world that was already on
the verge of disappearing
these were the last years that you could
convince yourself life
was normal in the roman republic the
last years before
the first triumvirate before caesar's
wars before
the bloody transition into the roman
empire still no one witnessing the boy's
birth could have possibly guessed that
he would be the one to benefit from all
this chaos that's not to say
octavian came from humble circumstances
the boy's father
also called gas octavius was a member of
the landed gentry at
veletre who'd had the fortune to marry
julius caesar's niece
although julius caesar wasn't yet the
historical colossus we know today
he was certainly on his way colossus or
not though octavia never saw much of
great-uncle julius in his childhood
and just to get this out of the way yes
it is customary to call him octavius
prior to 44 bc but since we're already
doing one name change to
augustus we're just going to call him
octavian until then
to avoid confusion when octavian was
only 4 his father died leaving him to be
educated by his grandmother
julia minor julia minor was caesar's
sister theoretically bringing octavia
closer to one of rome's most powerful
men
but only theoretically even if caesar
had paid much attention to the boy
it's doubtful he'd have liked what he
saw octavian was a weak sickly child who
was overly attached to his mother
all qualities the macho romans sneered
at yet even as a boy octavian showed a
knack for making friends with people who
had
strengths he was lacking people like the
athletic powerful
marcus agrippa but octavian also had
another secret quality
one which no one ever saw the boy
harbored an ambition that burned so
bright it could outshine the sun as
octavian grew up he slowly began to gain
some recognition
in 51 bc julia minor died and he was
chosen to deliver the oration at her
funeral
a few years later he became a member of
the board of priests or
pontificies a hugely desirable position
but it would be the action of his great
uncle that brought octavian
to the heart of power in 50 bc the
struggle for rome
was reaching its epic climax on one side
the general pompey and his supporters
were trying to force julius caesar
to give up governorship of gaul on the
other caesar and marc anthony were
trying to force pompeii out of politics
it was the final act in the collapse of
the first tromborette when it was over
only one of the former comrades would be
left standing
and well you already know who that's
going to be
on january the 10th 49 bc caesar marched
his troops across a small stream known
as the rubicon
and into history the boundary between
sesalpine gaul and italy itself the
rubicon was a big deal
crossing it with an army automatically
meant declaring war
it was this declaration that made
caesar's name
when pompey got news of the invasion he
fled italy leaving caesar to go chasing
after him
in the following years of bloodshed
octavian begged to be allowed to fight
alongside his great uncle but he was too
young
too much of a child for military life
nonetheless two events did come out of
the civil war that would transform
octavian's fortunes the first was his
friend marcus agrippa's brother being
captured by caesar
in north africa fighting for the
pompeians when agrippa got the news he
begged octavian to save his brother's
life
octavian duly asked caesar to forgive
the boy and to everyone's surprise
caesar agreed from that point on agrippa
would be
a die-hard octavian loyalist the second
was more indirect while fighting caesar
left his number two mark anthony
in charge of rome itself unfortunately
anthony was such a lazy frat boy that he
almost caused a revolution
when caesar returned in 46 bc he was so
pissed that
he sent antony into exile and just like
that julius caesar was suddenly in need
of a potential successor it was this
need more than anything that would set
octavian on the road to infamy
with anthony off sulking in gaul
octavian got to join caesar on the
triumville procession
for his african victory but this was
just a quick breather because in 45 bc
old julius galloped off again this time
to espania
to fight the sons of pompeii neues and
sextus
the plan was that young octavian would
go off with his great uncle
instead the boy was forced to watch in
horror as his body betrayed him
we mentioned earlier that octavian was
sickly but maybe we need to take a
moment here to emphasize
just how sickly he was all his life he
would be wracked by illnesses that would
put him out of action for months or even
years and left him stranded at death's
door just
shy of crossing the threshold it was one
of these crippling illnesses that
stopped him going with caesar but of
course
nobody in rome knew this they all
thought he was just a coward
this was a serious charge in ancient
rome more damaging than it would be
today
it left octavian with no choice
mustering the sort of willpower usually
reserved for ultramarathons octavian
forced his hurting body to leave his bed
to leave rome to ride out to hispania to
meet his great uncle
by the time he got there the war was
already won but it still turned out to
be
a wise move as caesar noted octavian
couldn't possibly have known the outcome
when he set off
meaning there was every chance he'd ride
into hispania and be massacred by
pompei's sons
in other words caesar was saying guys it
turns out my great nephew
is not a sniveling coward after all how
about that
the journey home was a mixed blessing
for octavian though
first the boy still only 18 got to ride
in caesar's carriage which was a huge
honor but then caesar decided to take a
detour and patch things up with mark
antony and it was anthony who rode with
caesar the rest of the way home still it
seems octavian had made a good
impression it would be
during this journey that caesar made the
history changing decision
to alter his will two thousand year old
spoiler alert here
it's not gonna end well for mark anthony
back in rome he's handed octavian a plum
role as a powerful administrator to
help him learn the ropes of politics at
the same time julius started acting more
and more like an ancient king
a that was lost on absolutely nobody
across 45 bc he pushed the senate into
extending his term as dictator and
pulled pr stunts like having laurel
crown secretly placed atop statues of
him in the city
come february 44 bc the senator decided
the only way to stop caesar from
literally becoming king was to
assassinate him yet when the ides of
march finally came
octavian wouldn't be around to witness
it that spring he and agrippa traveled
to apollina in what's now albania to
complete their military studies
and there they were on march 15th when
caesar's senators
stabbed the dictator to death marc
anthony on the other hand
was in rome when the news broke he fled
the city convinced that he would be next
cicero uttered a famous phrase the ides
of march was a fine deed
but half done he meant that no one had
killed anthony
no one had traveled to appolina to
murder octavian
instead it confused anthony slung back
in late march and resumed his consulship
one of his first acts was to open
caesar's will reading the contents must
have been like being drop kicked
in the nuts by caesar's ghost the will
stipulated that octavian would be
posthumously adopted by caesar not only
that the
boy would receive nearly all of his
fortune the moment anthony read these
words marked the beginning of a rivalry
between
the old soldier and octavian a bitter
nasty rivalry that would shape rome's
future
for generations and it would only be
over when
one or both of the men was finally dead
[Music]
news of the ides of march forced
octavian to make a life-changing
decision
should he return to rome or simply flee
into the night at the impromptu council
the boy held almost everyone was like
ah dude you should definitely run these
guys just killed your great uncle
you're probably gonna be next dude but
there was
one exception marcus agrippa by now a
powerful soldier declared this was
ancient bull poop of the highest order
he urged octavian to return to rome to
be a man
to claim his inheritance it would be far
from the only time
agrippa's advice saved octavian's butt
that spring the boy returned to the
eternal city to find events moving
rapidly marc anthony had successfully
whipped up the mob against the
conspirators
forcing assassins like cassius and
brutus to flee rome
less successful he also tried to make
out like caesar had actually left his
fortune to the roman people
and definitely not posthumously adopted
any heirs
so when octavian realized the truth he
also realized that anthony was
gunning for him and this was bad news
for anthony because
one of the cardinal rules of ancient
rome is
don't with octavian especially
not when you're already a walking pr
disaster zone
anthony's first major mistake was to try
and make peace with the senate having
riled up the mob this allowed octavian
to tell the mob look guys
he is betraying you and force anthony
into a corner
the second was to act so unstable that
guys like cicero became convinced
anthony was a danger to the republic and
began promoting octavian
as an alternative the third and probably
biggest mistake anthony made
was to go and invade salpine gaul the
reasons why are slightly complex
involving anthony's consulship ending
and the senate wanting to pack him back
off to macedonia
but basically it was designed to be a
show of force
for the senate this was just too much
anthony was declared an enemy of the
state in early 43 bc the senate
authorized octavian to take
two legions into cesar being gaul and
defeat the renegade general
but since octavian was still young and
untested they
didn't put him in charge of the campaign
instead the boy would have to serve
under two consoles
who would help keep him in line there's
good reason we're not mentioning
either of their names no sooner had
octavian got to cesarpin gaul then
he killed them both and seized control
of the anti-antony forces
so this must be it right the final
showdown between the two masked armies
of antony and octavian the
epic battle for rome's future well
not quite as the two men faced off
across the jagged mountainous terrain
they both seemed to have realized
something important they could fight now
wipe one another out and leave the
victor to limp home to
a smug and treacherous senate or or
they could join forces and become
unstoppable in october of 43 bc
after a whole lot of negotiating
octavian anthony and another caesar
loyalist named marcus emelius lepidus
met on a small island in a river there
they spent two days hammering out a
framework for their three-way alliance
an alliance that would dominate rome
for the next 13 years its name
the second triumvirate
amid the chaos of the octavian anthony
showdown the flight of cassius and
brutus to the east had
kind of been well maybe not forgotten
but certainly put to one side
but now the championship fight had been
postponed
all lies were back on the traitors from
its inception the second triumvirate
made tracking down the assassins its top
priority
for that they were going to need some
money the prescriptions of late 43 bc
funded the coming war by randomly
choosing 2 000 roman citizens to forfeit
their property and
lives but really there was nothing
random about it every single one of
those 2000 had pissed off either
octavian
anthony or lepidus lists of names were
posted and anyone
on those lists could be murdered without
consequence in all 300 senators bit the
dust alongside nearly 2 000 from
the equates class middle class romans
who owned land and had enough wealth to
own their own armor and horses among the
dead was anthony's old enemy and
octavian's friend cicero whose
badass death involved showing his
assassins his neck and declaring
get it right the first time with the
slaughter over octavian and anthony
headed east to kill the traitors leaving
lepidus in charge of rome the republic
that octavian and anthony temporary left
in 42 bc
was one as fractured as it had ever been
brutus and cassius hadn't just fled east
they now
basically were the east controlling huge
swaths of territory
at the same time a much smaller force of
republicans commanded the seas
among them was pompeii's son sextus
who'd miraculously escaped the war in
hispania yet
despite the circling sharks the second
triumvirate was still strong strong
enough that in september 42 bc they
tracked down
cassius and brutus and forced a battle
sadly for octavian
it was yet another moment when his body
gave out leaving anthony the one to go
marching out into battle and glory well
almost just like when he dragged himself
to hispania to be with caesar
octavian managed to pull his broken
frame onto the battlefield
to witness their triumph amusingly the
battle was actually a draw but cassius
watching from a hillside
could only see his own camp being
captured and assuming he'd lost
he committed suicide the following month
octavian and anthony likewise blew
through brutus's forces like
some sort of divine wind when brutus
ended his own life octavian removed his
head and
sent it back to rome to be displayed
before a statue of caesar
in the wake of their victory the
trambears parted ways with octavian
heading back to rome while anthony
stayed in the east
before they parted though octavian
signed an agreement with his rival
one which effectively split the republic
in three most of the west except
anthony's base of gaul went to octavian
most of the east went antony and
whatever crappy bits no one wanted were
sort of chucked to lepidus well that's
in theory at least in reality the
republic was actually divided between
four over in sicily sextus pompei was
having the time of his life establishing
his own kingdom and
blockading rome's ports when octavian
made it back to rome it wasn't to parade
around in triumph but to deal with the
massive headache
caused by food shortages and riots he
also had to deal with demobilizing his
own troops which involved confiscating
land for them to live on which
triggered yet more riots and all the
while anthony was off swanning around
the east looking
like the great hero he'd always fancied
himself as
at this stage if you're an outside
observer you'd probably have assumed
octavian
was the weak link here in a modern world
context his poles would be slumping snl
would have hired a baldwin brother to
impersonate him and he'd be repeatedly
committing pr blunders
like that time he held a banquet during
a
famine but as our era has repeatedly
shown
polls can be wrong in 41 bc octovian
might have looked like he was on the
ropes but in reality
he was now only a decade away from
becoming
the most powerful man on earth
unfortunately for you it doesn't take 10
years if you want to make a great
website with today's sponsor squarespace
it'll feel more like 10 seconds look
it's the new year so whatever that thing
you're thinking about doing is well it's
time to
do it with squarespace squarespace is
the platform to use
if you want to get started on that web
project you're thinking about
are you looking to get in and out quick
without thinking too much about
what your website should look like bam
use one of their quick beautiful
templates to make a website
that is fresh and for you it's like it's
right out of the box it's easy or maybe
you're a person who's a bit more
hands-on
you've got opinions about how you want
things to look well
customize that template however you want
or start from scratch also when you've
made your websites there's no updates
there's no patches there's no technical
bs to worry about
once you've done setting up your website
tinkering with the design of your sewing
clients there are also
a whole load of other features that
squarespace provides
so that your website can thrive email
campaigns
patronage portals social integrations
member-only areas
analytics commercial options do i need
to go on well i will
24 7 support look i've been partners
with squarespace for a long time even
longer than the lengths of this video
and i will say that i made a website for
one of my other channels mega projects
using squarespace you can find it at
megaprojects.net i have no design skills
no web skills whatsoever
and it was so easy and i just made this
i think it's simple but it's great
looking website using squarespace
megaprojects.net if you want to check it
out so when you're ready to get started
on
that next project of yours big or small
do it with squarespace go to
squarespace.com for a free trial when
you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com forward slash
biographics and you'll get 10
of your first purchase of a website or a
domain and let's get back to the boy who
would be emperor
although the second transvert would
officially last until 33 bc
it spent nearly its entire life on the
edge of violent collapse
it nearly fell apart in 41 bc as
octavian was reeling from the blockade
and riots
some of anthony's relatives tried to
overthrow the young triumvir
but as we've already noted the cardinal
rule of surviving rome
is do not with octavian the boy and
agrippa crushed the rebels
afterwards octavian marched north and
swiped antony's province of gaul for
anthony this was like octavian had just
kicked his way into his house pissed on
his playstation 5 and molested his
mother
the general was livid so livid he tried
to ally with sextus pompeii to finish
the boy off
so octavian got the drop on him actually
marrying sextus's aunt scribonia
to win him over and while we're probably
not going to mention scribonia again in
this video
just know that she was far from a
historical nobody one of her
great-grandsons would become emperor
caligula while her great-great-grandson
would be emperor nero not bad for a
two-line side character
anyway the upshot of all of this was
that anthony flew off the handle and
laid siege to rome and octavian
came out to fight him but by now
everyone was so fed up with all of this
civil warring that
both of their legions refused to do
battle they basically just said
nah we're pretty tired guys just figure
it out yourselves alright
so once again a final battle between the
two great rivals was averted
instead anthony let octavian take back
gaul while anthony married the boy's
sister
octavia that done the chamber negotiated
peace with sextus and
the moment it was agreed octavian
divorced the hell out of poor old
scrubonia
on the exact same day she gave birth to
his daughter julia
and jacked up instead with livia
drusilla since livia
already had a child at this stage and
that child was the future emperor
tiberius this would turn out to be
a fateful marriage after that it was
right back
to scheming and warring as anthony
headed back east octavian tried his best
to finally defeat sextus but while he
might have been cunning
he simply didn't have the tactical
skills sextus ran
or should we say sailed rings around him
culminating in a 38 bc naval battle that
nearly killed the boy
in the midst of war the triumvirate's
first term expired and anthony demanded
they trade 120 of his ships for four of
octavian's legions to keep the deal
alive
octavian being octavian was all like
yeah sure thing did
and took anthony's ships and then
refused to send to many legions
presumably or while
laughing his ass off but what could
anthony do by 36 bc
octavian's fortunes were already turning
his forces under marcus agrippa defeated
sextus that year
ending octavian's last challenge to
power when fellow trambir labridas tried
to claim
sextus's old territory octavian removed
him from his post and
shunted him off to the important but
powerless role of pontifex maximus
lepidus wisely took the job
without complaint that left only mark
anthony standing between
octavian and his ambitions luckily it
was around this exact same time the
wheels started to fall off
the anthony train while octavian was
finding his feet in rome anthony had
been busy getting his butt kicked
invading parthia
and then parading around alexandria like
a new pharaoh in waiting
at this point ptolemaic egypt was still
independent even if cleopatra relied on
the graces of the romans to survive
but once anthony shacked up with the
queen he started doing stuff like
declaring her son
caesarean the offspring of cleopatra's
time with julius caesar
king of kings from a roman perspective
this was the screw-up to end
all screw-ups anthony was trying to
kneecap octavian's claim to
being caesar's only heir but the
impression he gave off was
of someone about to hand half of rome to
a bunch of egyptian hicks
it was beyond stupid now all octavian
had to do
was not make any mistakes of his own and
the people
would by default rally behind him and
that's exactly what happened
over the next few years octavian
concentrated on shoring up support
throwing public games while
simultaneously spreading propaganda
about
anthony going native while anthony tried
to fire back claiming octavian only
became caesar's heir
after seducing the old man he simply
wasn't very good at this game
when the triumvirate's second term
expired at the end of 33 bc
it was octavian who made a big song and
dance about voluntarily giving up power
leaving anthony looking like the evil
tyrant unwilling to relinquish control
of course octavian didn't actually give
up anything more than a title he still
wielded power like a dictator
causing a third of the senate to leave
rome and join anthony and alexandria but
it was the public perception
that really mattered and octavian was a
master
of the dark arts of ancient pr the
climax to the now
ex-trombo's war of words came in 32 bc
that year anthony divorced octavian's
sister an outrageous act of disrespect
in response octavian stormed into the
sacred temple where anthony's will was
held and removed it
it was a crazy move to disrespect a
temple could have sent octavian's stock
plummeting
but then octavian read the will and
realized his gamble had paid off
anthony had bequeathed the entire east
of the republic
to the non-roman queen cleopatra an act
of treason
it was the death knell of anthony's
support in rome soon after the senate
authorized octavian to go to war
but in the end it wouldn't be octavian
who destroyed anthony it would be
anthony's
own bone-headed stupidity although
anthony set off to fight at the head of
a vast fleet he was too scared to just
go
charging in and invade italy so he
hunkered his ships down
in a bay on the ionian sea a bay which
marcus agrippa then blockaded on behalf
of octavian
trapping anthony in a miserable siege
over the next few months agrippa's
blockade starved anthony as in
they literally starved him many of his
men died of malnutrition
at the same time octavian funneled
troops overland to cut off anthony's
escape
finally on september the 2nd 31 bc a
weak and desperate anthony tried to
smash the blockade
with his remaining ships it would be a
career-ending disaster
the battle of actium was such a
one-sided affair that it became
synonymous with miserable defeat sort of
like
waterloo if napoleon had just been
really
really bad at war anthony's navy was
annihilated although he and cleopatra
managed to escape
they lost everything her upsult in the
wound octavian then offered clemency to
the survivors
allowing anthony's men to demobilize
with honor the message
was clear this is about anthony desert
him now
and you will be spared it was a message
that would quickly find its audience
all throughout the winter of 31-30 bc
octavian and agrippa prepared for an
invasion of egypt
although the winds was in their sails
they knew this could be a tough fight
egypt was home turf anthony what would
it take to break his rule
in the end the answer was not much that
spring octavian's forces advanced on
egypt for the final assault as octavian
himself pushed down overland through
syria his vast navy descended on
alexandria
yet there would be little fighting at
the sight of octavian and agrippa
bearing down on them
teeth bared and eyes blazing anthony's
men muttered the latin equivalent of
screw this and mass deserted by the time
octavian reached the city his old rival
had already committed suicide
still octavian had his fun he had
cleopatra brought before him made her
beg for her life and then
agreed to spare her but only after
stripping her of everything and parading
her in humiliation
through the streets of rome rather than
face this fate though
cleopatra committed suicide after that
all that was left for octavian was
to have the teenage cesarean executed
eliminating his last possible rival
at last he was rome's unchallenged
master
so here we are then way over 20 minutes
in about the time in any normal video
where we'd thank you for watching thank
the sponsor squarespace tell you to
smash that like button
and roll the credits but this isn't a
normal video this is a video about
octavian
probably the most important figure in
the whole
history of rome a guy who did so much
vital stuff that telling his story
within a normal time frame would just be
impossible we have already watched him
change the course of history
fighting through multiple civil
conflicts we saw him avenge his uncle
destroy marc anthony
and take over the entire republic but as
we warned you in the introduction
this is only the beginning for the
victorious octavian lording over a
defeated egypt aged only 33
the real work was yet to come
in the wake of octavian's victory the
political map of the mediterranean was
radically redrawn no longer were the
western and eastern parts of the roman
republic split into two zones of
influence
no longer was egypt independent although
it hadn't exactly been absorbed into
rome
either instead egypt yep the whole of
egypt became octavian's personal
possession instantly making him one of
the wealthiest men
in history nor was it just egypt less
than 30 months after anthony's bitter
end the boy strong-armed the senate into
granting him dominion over gaul hispania
and syria in other words octavian now
had his own private empire
within the wider republic but it wasn't
just on the maps that the state of play
changed there were transformations
behind the scenes as well most obviously
this came in the slate of executions
octavian ordered
against anthony loyalists if you were
the governor of some region that had
sided with the dead general
well sorry but now octavian was going to
calmly add your body to his confirmed
kill count
no hard feelings that being said while
octavian was ruthless as hell he was
also capable of flashes of magnaminity
a surprising number of anthony's old
friends survived the purge surprising in
the sense that the number
wasn't zero including random historical
crossover alert
king herod the great but octavian's
maneuverings went
beyond just slaughter the entire
political class was shaken up leaving
only those loyal to or scared of
octavian
still the boy was always careful not to
repeat julius caesar's mistake of
actually making himself look like a
tyrant in january 27 bc he even made a
big deal of announcing his retirement
from public life
of course it was all a ruse the senate
begged him to stay until octave was all
like
no all right then in a spasm
of pathetic joy the senate responded by
endowing him with the title
of revered one or as we better know it
augustus from this point on octavian the
ruthless ambitious boy would vanish
replaced by augustus the ruthless
ambitious man and unlike with octavius
earlier
this time will likewise be changing the
way we refer to him
following his latest honor first citizen
augustus left rome to
tour his new possessions heading off de
gaulle and hispania to fight some wars
unfortunately his sickly body gave out
once again and augustus spent more than
a year laid up in hispania
almost at death's door yet his recovery
and return to rome in 24 bc would only
be
a respite in 23 bc augustus fell
deathly ill even for a man who'd spent
his entire life in a kind of protracted
dance with the grim reaper
this was next level staff everyone
assumed
that it was the end which was a serious
problem unlike julius caesar before him
augustus did not have an heir shaw had
spent the last few years grooming both
livia's son tiberius and his own nephew
marcus claudius marcellus for the role
but they were both still too young
certain he was dying desperate to place
the empire in the hands of someone he
could trust
augustus did the only logical thing he
made marcus agrippa his heir
this was an excellent choice agrippa was
popular respected
and on good terms with the senate
possibly a little too good when the
senator they were all like great
don't let the door hit you on your way
out augustus all right and this isn't a
joke most of them would have been happy
if the first citizen
had died then and there sadly for them
augustus clung
onto life by a miracle and when he
recovered
he made sure to demonstrate once again
that cardinal rule
of rome on july the 1st 23 bc
augustus effectively made the senate
hand over its remaining power
the moment they acquiesced is notable
for being the last possible moment you
can date the death
of the roman republic to since it's not
an exact science the end date of the
republic is traditionally placed at
either cicero's murder in 43 bc or
octavian's transformation into augustus
16 years later although some people
think that's jumping the gun
no one has any doubt about where things
lay by july of 23 bc
however you cut it the roman republic
was 100 dead and buried
after augustus's latest power grab from
now on
our story is taking place within the
roman empire
[Music]
the new empire got off to a rocky start
at least on a personal level at the end
of 23 bc
augustus's nephew marcellus died leaving
him suddenly short of bears with the
docile senate clearly pining for agrippa
the first citizen
began to get paranoid by making his old
friend his heir had he
actually just created a dangerous new
rival for himself
but if you're expecting to now hear that
augustus did a bit of classic roman
empering and
had a grip of fed to the lions just know
that that's not how this particular
story shakes out
agrippa had been his best friend since
childhood murder and open conflict
were off the table if augustus was going
to both neutralize the agrippa threat
and keep his friend alive there was only
one possible option
the wedding of marcus agrippa took place
in 21 bc
his bride was augustus's 18 year old
daughter julia remember her the baby was
born literally the same day ogdavian
divorced her mother to play
the salami with livia with the gripper
now his son-in-law augustus no longer
had to worry about him getting any ideas
not that agrippa ever would have he was
steadfastly loyal to
augustus as he always had been far from
scheming his way to the top he was
happy to settle down with julia and sire
a bunch of kids
one of these kids would become known to
history as agrippina the elder when she
grew up she'd marry a dude called
germanicus and have her own boy
named little boot so why are we telling
you this well that's because the latin
for little boot
is caligula as in the utterly banana's
future emperor honestly all these family
tree digressions
are one of the most fascinating aspects
of augustus's later life
at the same time he was laying the
foundations for the empire he was also
laying the foundations for the family
that would shape its early fortunes
tiberius caligula claudius nero these
are names
etched into history recognizable even 2
000 years later and it's all thanks to
augustus's dynastic
games that most of them ever existed
speaking of laying the empire's
foundations we should probably talk
about augustus's reforms when the first
citizen came to power roman bureaucracy
was like a creaking
old decaying ship just one more hole
away from completely capsizing bribery
was rampant the private tax collection
system was so
open to abuse that it encouraged
extortion vital official positions
changed hands yearly and were frequently
political appointments meaning
everyone running the show was mostly
looking out for number one
augustus threw the whole rotten system
out it was augustus who
brought in rome's first professional
class of civil servants chosen on merit
it was augustus who
took not only tax collection into state
ownership but
also the city of rome's fire and police
departments suddenly your house bursting
into flames was no longer just your
problem
just as bad roads blighting the
provinces were no longer just
something for the hicks to whine about
augustus upgraded the empire's
infrastructure repairing old roads
building new ones and
instituting a standing navy to patrol
the mediterranean protect
ships granted this was all way less
exciting than octavian and anthony
chasing each other around the world and
doing battle but
you know what in the long run it was
probably more important the realm that
augustus took over was old
and dysfunctional it might not have
quite been on the verge of collapse but
it also
wasn't going to survive clear to 476 a.d
without a serious overhaul well augustus
was the guy
who slapped it into shape and he did
such a damn good job that
even the appearance of multiple crappy
emperors who followed him
could not break it apart he turned the
army into a professional fighting force
paid for
from the state treasury up to this point
rome's armies had traditionally relied
on their generals for money meaning guys
like
caesar or you know octavian effectively
controlled legions free from oversight
under augustus all of that changed
incentives were removed for soldiers to
place their loyalty in their leaders and
replaced with incentives like pensions
for veterans and care for the wounded to
place their loyalty in the empire
taken together these reforms transformed
the empire all but guaranteeing it
a long and healthy life sadly the major
lesson here that statecraft relies
as much on the boring stuff as the
conquering and drama
would be a lesson most of augustus's
heirs
forgot to learn
[Music]
the trouble with doing long videos like
these even when they're twice the normal
length
is that it's all too easy to fall into
portraying our subjects as either
wholly good or wholly bad it saves time
it streamlines the narrative and stops
things from
getting overly complex however that's
not what history's actually like
rarely are people just straight up
awesome or totally incompetent
sociopaths so having just talked up the
first citizen
let's tear him down a little by
examining his darker side
one of the least popular aspects of
augustus's entire reign
was morality laws today we have an image
of rome as a pretty hedonistic place but
that wasn't always the case
especially not under a prude like
augustus beginning in 18 bc the first
citizen
set off on a crusade against immorality
including a controversial law that made
adultery a crime against
the state that meant adulterers could be
punished in court and if they were
female
they could even be killed at the same
time augustus tried to promote marriage
bringing in additional laws designed to
make
unmarried life expensive miserable and
not worth the effort
the twist augustus himself was a serial
adulterer screwing around
rome like some sort of rich hypocritical
rabbit
another strike against the first citizen
had to be the war
in germania determined to expand the
empire's borders all the way to elba
augustus declared war against all the
tribes to the north
in 17 bc it would be a long bloody
pointless affair eventually culminating
in the battle of the teuteberg forest in
9ad
it's one of the only times the roman
army was thoroughly stomped
by an outside force that stomping was so
complete that it essentially ended roman
expansionism
right up until claudius invaded britain
some 40 years later
so yeah don't go thinking augustus's
only deal was
enlightened despotism and making the
empire
a better place but while all this
important stuff was going on
augustus's mind was laser focused
elsewhere
on the question that would preoccupy the
rest of his reign
ensuring that he had an heir with
marcellus dead
the first citizen still had tiberias to
fall back on along with his stepson
drusis but while they were fine lads
they weren't blurred so augustus got
right back to his old dynastic games
first he forced both tiberias and
dresses to marry into his wider family
ensuring he'd have some link to their
children and again we get to see the
future unfold a bit here because
dresses would father both germanicus aka
caligula's dad
and the future emperor claudius yeah we
know this family tree
is insane but still it is very cool to
see how much the empire's first century
is owed to augustus forcing everyone to
marry each other the second thing
augustus did was to adopt the two sons
marcus agrippa
had fathered with julia from a young age
gaius and lucius were
raised by augustus for the first citizen
they must have been the perfect
combination his blood
via his daughter julia mixed with that
of his eldest
and most loyal friend how could things
possibly go wrong
sadly for the future of rome going very
wrong was
what things were about to be all about
the first blow came in 12 bc
that year marcus agrippa traveled to the
balkans aged 51
to prepare for an upcoming military
campaign while there he contracted a
nasty disease and although his people
tried to return him to rome
he died on route when augustus got the
news he was devastated
riding out he accompanied the body on
its journey back to rome where
he ordered a gripper to be interred in
his own mausoleum
it's curious to imagine what must have
been going through augustus's minds on
that journey
there right there was the body of the
man who'd been with him since the
beginning
the guy who'd talked him into returning
to rome following the ides of march
who'd been the key to his triumph over
anthony
it's possible augustus was aware that
his life had just crossed its own
rubicon a point
from which there was no going back with
the grip of dead the first citizen
was now on his own and while it wouldn't
be all downhill from here
it was certainly going to be difficult
[Music]
the death of marcus agrippa was followed
with yet more bad news
in 9 bc juices fell from his horse and
died
leaving augustus again short on airs
although he was still raising agrippa's
sons gaius and lucius they
were both way too young to take over if
another illness carried the first
citizen away
so augustus turned his attention fully
onto tiberius
promoting him and even making him marry
agrippa's widow julia but augustus had
forgotten or perhaps
never learned a simple fact of human
psychology
people don't like being told what to do
they don't
like being forced to divorce their wives
and marry older women they have nothing
in common with
the dumb abstract ideas all of which may
be why in 6 bc tiberius abruptly
upped and left he just went off to roads
and refused to come back
refused to have anything more to do with
his stepdad augustus
raged and exerted all the pressure he
could but the always moody tiberius had
simply had enough
he was gone and that was that the wrench
this threw into the works was big enough
to destabilize
everything although augustus began
investing heavily in gaius and lucius it
seemed
fate was determined to laugh at him in
the year 280 lucius died of an illness
on route to gaul
aged only 19. two years later 24 year
old gaius went
and got himself wounded during the siege
of a town the wound got infected
and well that was it for gaius now
agrippa and julia had another son
one born just after agrippa died but he
grew up to be such a nasty violent
bastard that
augustus refused to even let him live in
rome banishing him to a remote island
and so it was that in 680 the first
citizen came to a miserable realization
if he wanted an heir he was going to
have to beg tiberius to return
for a guy who never had to beg for
anything it must have been the most
humiliating dish he'd ever had to
swallow
for tiberius though it was party time
within a couple of years of flouncing
off tiberius had realized it made a
mistake but
a combination of his own pride and
augustus's epic grudge holding had
kept him from coming back now though the
moment of his tranquil return
had at last arrived and this was
something of a problem for everyone in
rome because tiberius already had a bit
of a reputation of being a massive
he might not have been a
monster but tiberius was
surely uncooperative and egotistical so
few people wanted tiberius on the
imperial throne that augustus had to
force him to adopt his dashing
20-year-old nephew germanicus
meaning that no matter how crappy
tiberius's reign was
the next emperor after him would be a
popular hero
and you'll have to jump ahead and watch
our tiberius and caligula videos to see
just how badly fate
screwed up that particular plan the
return of tiberius to rome
marks the effective end of augustus's
time as a significant ruler
sure he remained emperor for several
more years and even found time to make
an impact on the literary world both by
writing deeds of the divine augustus
and the exiling poet over for reasons
that still remain
tantalizingly mysterious but the main
act of his life
was over and by now the old man knew it
in 980 augustus withdrew from public
life pending most of the day-to-day
running of state over to tiberius
no sooner was he in charge than tiberius
began a slow crackdown on people's
rights that
would foreshadow his own authoritarian
regime but of course
augustus wouldn't be around to see this
in early 1480
augustus retired to a villa below mount
vesuvius laying low again
thanks to another recurrent bout with
illness this time however there would be
no miraculous recovery
no return from the brink finally after a
lifetime spent on the threshold of death
augustus at last stepped through the
door
we can only hope that as he did so he
saw his old friend marcus agrippa there
on the other side
waiting for him augustus died on august
19 14ad
at the age of 76. at this point he had
ruled rome for over four decades the
longest reign of any emperor
shaping the fortunes of the empire in
ways that no one would ever replicate
accordingly his funeral procession
was enormous after his cremation the
first citizen was deified as a god yet
even then
dead and buried augustus still had an
impact on official policy
augustus's will exhorted those who
followed him to not expand the empire
any further and with the exception of
claudius conquering britain
no other emperor would go against this
until trajan arrived
nearly a century later at the end of
that epic life then
what is left to say about the man once
known as
octavian without a doubt he remains one
of the most important people to have
ever lived
excluding founders of religions he is
very possibly
the most important pick any other
so-called great man of history whether
they're napoleon bonahart abraham
lincoln simon bolivar or genghis khan
their brilliance is a mere pinprick of
light next to that
of augustus a firefly beside a supernova
this is the guy who created the roman
empire
who laid the foundations for a
superpower that would last another 450
years
without augustus the whole of western
history looks completely different
household names like claudius and nero
never even existed
but even taking away the butterfly
effect stuff augustus was a man who
demands to be remembered as the first
citizen himself
once truthfully said i found rome a city
of bricks
and i left it a city of marble what
better epitar
could there be for the sickly young boy
who grew up to be rome's first
and greatest emperor so i really hope
you found that video
interesting it was a long one doing
these is
a big effort and you can support that
effort by supporting our fantastic
sponsor squarespace who i'm linking to
below
thank you for watching